hey welcome good to see you guys in good
spirits
uh boys yeah I
I mean it's kind of his thing right no
yeah
uh so you guys are are together correct
we are together you guys I feel like we
always see when you guys
all right
[Music]
so here we go again
what I'm just trying to keep up what's
going on with y'all that has you had to
answer the questions he said yeah all
right that's why I don't want to do
anything
why he's just playing like he's just
playing answer the [__] question for
him
right how dry she doesn't want to be no
humor In This Moment it's not humor it's
a question
you did it you said yeah all right
technically an answer
yeah get your own catchphrase well good
to see you guys Krishan how are you
doing
great you're doing good
how are you dealing with um all the like
kind of like
Newfound stardom because you are kind of
like
every other day viral as hell you know
what I'm saying your music career is
taking off your TV star now how do you
deal with all the kind of being the
the uh
I guess between the two of y'all you
might somebody say you more popping than
blue now
hell yeah
I don't know I don't care
you don't care no it's cool yeah that's
it is it hard to deal with like
everybody in y'all's business all the
time though
that's whatever
yeah
what put them all up in the [__]
business
all types of [__] so
well at least you guys I mean look it's
good to see you guys back together you
know if only for a while there uh you
know Super Bowl weekend seemed kind of
rough for y'all
for sure
you were getting bags I'm sure Super
Bowl week I saw you like at every party
in Arizona
for free he came to my party
it was a good time you were like that
I'm here to have fun bye everyone I work
every weekend so one week and I get off
yeah wait I'm outside super weekend
the game was lit